one sentence erases every accomplishment
that I've ever done I would like you see
some kind of a redemption story come
back with you sometimes you're not ready
for success
I wasn't most hatred that comes from me
personally there's a story about me
bumping them that I totally did and I
did it with impunity you said you
weren't [ __ ] I won't quote ya cuz you
can't tell me what you get on stage
would you say you stole jokes my jokes
are passion they're not written tamo no
oh god you're so wrong when I was a
young comic not only did I steal dose I
emulated these guys I did it the way
Paul Rodriguez did it I did it the way
Freddie Prinze did it I did it the way
George Carlin did it he here's a guy who
accused me of stealing jokes but not not
his that's never happened before in
comedy
so either Joe there's a pathological
liar he's either a sociopath or he's
telling the truth
or he had a personal problem with dude
Joe doesn't come across as a liar
pattern or so I come across as a lie I
think you're sick of what I'm trying to
tell you I've recorded every single show
since 1993 I can actually tell you when
I wrote a joke for the first time I
would say when did you write you know
all apologize did you ever think you
would make it my Philip's like it takes
sweet victory I know this life
yeah yeah why would you bet on Goliath
well we got red tape value taemin given
values contagious this world of
entrepreneurs we can't no value the
haters honey run homie look what I
become I'm the one
[Music]
so back in a 4-2 round oh seven oh eight
my guest was pretty much the face of
comedy many would say Carlos Mencia
until he had his friendly interaction
with Joe Rogan and things change a
little bit I'm gonna be a guest today
Carlos thanks for coming always did
always always so how are things man how
you doing I'm good I'm good a lot of
therapy seriously yeah big-time big-time
big-time it's uh you know people
sometimes you're not ready for success
and what comes with I wasn't in the
sense that when I grew up in the hood
and in the hood it's the opposite in the
hood everybody makes fun of you for
doing something that's outside the box
but once you achieve some kind of
success everybody's supportive of you
you know what I mean it's like I'm
looking at Tupac and here's a song I
love the hood it's all good when I go
back it that's how I found I wasn't
ready for the level of for the level of
hate for the level of animosity for the
level of jealousy for for all of it you
know what I mean it just wasn't but it
wasn't a part of my upbringing wasn't
upon one of 18 kids so for me sharing
was such a big part of it you know I
helped out so many comedians that I just
didn't I didn't see any of that stuff
coming I mean like the Joe Rogan thing
he here's a guy who accused me of
stealing jokes but not not hits so
that's never happened before in comedy
right it's never happened worse normally
it's like hey man you did my joke it's
not hey man you do somebody joke it that
just doesn't happen in in our business
it doesn't work that song what do you
mean by that so what was so how do you
like if you're a comedian yeah and you
think I did something or I think you did
something then we approach each other
okay but it's never had never been the
case where somebody was accusing me that
it had nothing to do with him well
Carlos I mean I understand you were
saying that but to to to get a
lightweight comedian to call you out on
stealing his jokes but it wasn't his
jokes that's my I get that what I'm
saying to you is he was to me the way I
see like the way I interpret what Joe
did is the idea of you know you're in
school you got a guy that's being
bullied by another guy hypothetically
okay that guy cannot stand up to the
bully because he controls the market he
was a bully I wasn't the bullied hear me
out let me interpret a you see where I'm
going with okay so look you have to the
one thing we have to say you're a very
talented guy everyone knows you're very
talented there is no disputing that
everybody knows when you're up there in
your your storytelling style it's just
your timing you know when you talk to
company you know comedians I've had
Kevin hard-on I've had some other people
on that it's all about timing
you can't teach that like you know the
timing aspect of hidden get going to
tell a joke yeah
yeah you got some of that stuff going on
but what I'm saying is when you said
things changed until until Rogan came
and called you out on stealing other
people's jokes the point I was trying to
make was a following in high school
I'm a big guy yeah I'm six five to forty
right I'm in the army right and I don't
need to fight like there's not a UH I
don't need to go out and fight anybody
people don't want to fight me right I
don't fight for myself right I would
fight for private Rudy at our unit who
is being bullied and you know four guys
being picked on and he's afraid of the
bully then I would come in to defend him
to say hey what are you doing messing
with would it come mess with me so
that's how I interpret what yeah it was
going to defend the other guys that were
afraid to harden you out what yeah but
there was no fear that I'd have I'd have
any power I didn't what can I do
Arlo's I didn't come on no dude what
power did I have I don't have any power
did not have any power you're getting
right into you of course you have power
do what dude I can tell you easy to what
you could do we do how to do what okay
let me explain okay so all the comedy
clubs are owned by five guys right
pretty much I mean okay it's a fair to
say that's right okay yeah so it's it's
very similar to a banking okay and if I
want to buy a house nowadays you're
really getting a loan from five
different banks maybe 20 years ago
different story
right you're going through five
different banks that ever since things
got national rights you know what what
happened with you know bailing people
out we gotta make sure be a very well
sir case you know the names everyone
knows in it so if I'm a
lightweight and I'm trying to come up
okay and if I say hey you know this
guy's stealing my jokes and if I say to
you you get pissed off
you call one of those owners and say hey
you if owners wouldn't do that owners
wouldn't do would not do that they they
would not do they wouldn't protect your
would protect your money guys no car
knew that they would not do that they
wouldn't they have standards man you
think they didn't listen capitalist I've
recorded every single show since 1993
every single show very rare exception
time I can actually tell you when I
wrote a joke for the first time so
whenever I was approached by anybody I
would say when did you write the joke I
still say that tell me when the joke was
written I could literally go check
digitally I've been recording the shows
since 93 all right so and anytime that's
ever happened all this stuff it like
goes away those accusations go away if
it was if it was the way that you
portray it to be and there was a
propensity to do it there would be
thousands of jokes or at least hundreds
of jokes on the internet of stuff that I
did the stuff that I accused stuff that
Ari Shaffir accused me of
he accused me of stealing a joke about
the wall right we get rid of Mexicans
we're gonna build the wall who's gonna
build the wall
that joke was literally told by 10
different comedians on comedy specials
you know the only one who stole it
me that's just a fact that's a complete
fact so that that was the hard part for
me because when somebody would say like
like you I would say tell me what joke
tell me who did it I'll go check it and
and if I would if I did it last
I'll apologize up up I'll see I'm sorry
I'll do whatever it takes that that's
not how this went down this this was a a
personal thing plus when you say
personal things like Joel was a personal
thing with you
sure of course it was I mean go go in
the Internet if it was about me stealing
jokes then why is it that the fact that
my birth name is Ned is an issue the
fact that supposedly I'm German is an
issue the fact that I'm not Mexican is
an issue allsey that all these attacks
came at me at the same time so that's
what I wasn't ready for I wasn't
prepared but you're still you're sick
was you know the Mexican jokes like your
stick was you know my mom's Mexican no I
get that but also the shots you're
getting is a part of it that hey the
name Carlos Mencia is better than a net
that that is a way better name in our
business we do the opposite and that is
a better name than Carlos Mencia in
America why don't you use Ned because
when I first started doing stand-up yeah
the owner of the comedy club Mitsy she
said you can't be an angry Mexican named
Ned so I said well I'm from Honduras and
she said you can't be an angry Mexican
named Ned and she said that's that's
what your people think you're Mexican
and I said my mom's Rex again and she
said well then you're Mexican and then
she said but you can't be Ned and I said
I got an uncle named Carlos and she said
Carlos Mencia and I have a card sniper
by Mitzi shore paulie's mom the owner of
the Comedy Store 1988 and she changed it
but going back right the norm is to
change your name from something ethnic
to something not ethnic that's that's
the norm to go American so to take
actually you know a name like Ned yeah
and then turn it into Carlos that's the
opposite of what anybody was doing I
embraced my heritage as opposed to
pushing it away and even that was you
know thrown at me as a negative thing I
don't I don't think that's the top
though it could be one of them but I
don't think that's the main stick that
kind of off but my point is is that if
it's about joke stealing what is all
this other stuff about is my point let
me ask you this question like I really
didn't know I'm like I'm gonna give her
from a different point of view I I would
like you see some kind of a redemption
story come back with you I'd like to see
that so confronting me from a peel via I
don't have you know what I'm trying to
say dude I did therapy I told you I've
been through my suicidal moments brah I
know III understand that but all I'm
saying to you is I'm coming from a place
of I'm neutral I'm not in your world all
I got
so I'm just kind of absorbing to say I
like did entertainment sure you know I
love Chappell you know he's going out
there doing he's and I love hard so I
paid a lot of money to go watch Hart I
bought hard to perform in front of my
guys and I put insurance executives
watching this guy dropping f-bombs
offline right right and I loved it right
because I think humor is a very
important aspect of a country when
you're going through a lot of challenges
and everyone's divided we need more Jon
Stewart's we need more Chappelle's I
need more hearts we need more brokenness
because I think it's bringing some of
that I guess my outcome of the
conversation with you is to follow my
outcome would be to see if when you're
looking back right now and if you look
at the issues right okay one is the the
one would Rogen we're on it you brought
it right off the bat and we're talking I
brought it up and you kind of went right
into it the Rogen part about stealing
okay when I call Iran and I say what's
the biggest frustrating frustration here
with him stealing jokes like I said
what's the biggest frustration okay this
is what I get and I'm doing my research
before what's your biggest frustration
oh you know stealing jokes what's
happening okay so what's your issue with
it well you know a bit as a joke and
when somebody is telling a joke you know
there you have the premise you have this
you have the tag and when you're going
through it and here's what happens so
you know why did the chicken cross the
street well because of this but because
you know here's what here's what I want
so but if you say it identically as that
and you don't give credit to the writers
that pisses people off this is why the
lightweight writers that don't have the
platform that maybe you Carlos has why
didn't they give credit to some of these
guys all you have to do is maybe like
what a junior what's Junior how do you
say it's last name Jay Mohr yeah Jay
Mohr right so you hear the stories about
hey look I like these riders I paying
500 bucks they write something for me I
get out and I perform it shows normal
it's okay right and then there was yeah
that's paying for a job that's no
problem you can do that not a problem
and then and then some of it came back
saying but Pat this guy the part that
pissed off a lot of people was the the
lightweight comedians were frightened of
Carlos because Carlos could shut down
their career at that time because let me
just finish at that time he's coming up
and when he did it
initially he didn't just come out and
say
look I screwed up I got caught Dane Cook
Robin Williams Amy I mean not Amy
Schumer Foley didn't apologize but
there's a few them there just came us I
screwed up and then BOOM
they went back to their stick in their
career why don't our was just coming on
and say I did it I screwed up but when I
move on but see here's what I said
here's what I said you
I said I'd recorded all my shows so I
have evidence to tell me what joke it is
I never hear that see what do you mean
you never use when when somebody says or
has ever said to me hey you took a joke
I'll say well when did you do it because
I have a record off I'll find out when
and all else I'll hear something like
well you know what you did and that's it
that that's all I'll hear whenever on
minor Mencia we did jokes that were
built on even premises that other people
did
we actually brought them in and not only
made them writers for a day but paid
them to be writers on the show so which
happened like three or four times but
outside of that I don't I don't know
what to say to somebody when they say
you took my joke and I say okay when did
you do it what's the joke and then they
walk away I don't know what what to do
because all the stories are you here
I hear none of that and think about this
you brought up Amy Schumer you brought
up Dane Cook yeah why is it that when
they get accused it goes away well what
is it about Carly just said okay I
screwed oh they didn't apologize
Dane Cook actually did louis c.k show
back in the day where they did a bit
where he actually said why would I take
the joke from you I'm Dane Cook I don't
need your joke it was a whole bit that
they did there was ever an apology Amy
Schumer never apologized that Robin
Williams apologized not that I know of
the story is that he would pay people
that's the story so so let me ask you so
so let's just say they do okay for you
by the way did you say I'm open to it
like I'm not saying you know I'm saying
you been around this day for a while
would you say you stole jokes here's
what I would say when I first started
like every comedian I wasn't me I was a
version of a bunch of comedians that I
thought were funny right right okay once
I shed that
I was waiting just like every other
comic but my problem was blinders that
when I was when I was a young comedian
and I had a ten o'clock spot I would get
up at 12:00 12:30 because Paul Mooney
showed up and did 45 minutes Eddie
Griffin did 45 minutes dice showed up
and did an hour and so they weren't on
the schedule mm-hmm
but they got to you know that's the way
the club business worked so by the time
2004 five came around that I had my show
it was different young comedians didn't
understand didn't appreciate most most
hatred that comes from me personally
there's a story about me bumping them or
pushing them or that they had a spot at
10:00 and they didn't go on because
you're doing that oh yeah I got that I
did oh and you know you don't do that
you say you were an [ __ ] I won't push
yeah okay oh but not an [ __ ] because
I was following the rules just the rules
changed you know what I mean that when
you say rules culture this was the
culture was the best that I showed up
and whoever was there you're awesome
doesn't matter yeah so but I started
getting why is he going on even like if
you listen to Marc Maron's podcast yeah
the WTF podcast it starts off with
here's the story I was at The Improv I
had a spot that I totally did do and I
did it with impunity but then again I
grew up at the Comedy Store
I didn't show up at The Comedy Store
from Madison and I was a hot young guy
and five six years into it when I'm good
I showed up I started in the petri dish
of comedy so I didn't get to shed those
those years of you know being some other
comedian at some of the place I did it
on the stage at The Comedy Store on
Sunset Boulevard for everybody to see so
that part yeah the the going on before
other people part yeah but I felt like I
deserved it because I paid the price
myself you know I stayed
my brother can tell you my wife can tell
you you know I'd come home at 3 o'clock
in the morning because I had a spot at 1
in front of 8 drunk people that's how I
built my chops so that part is is the
part that I had to deal with the part
that I know that I can embrace and by
the way if I had taken a bunch of other
people's stuff I would've I would have
wanted to apologize the whole thing was
you're still saying you you haven't no
when I just told you what I did right
you're saying what your answer was my
interpretation which you said is when I
feel and everybody else was doing no no
that's what your answer no no what I'm
saying is when I first started doing
comedy yeah I was a version of a bunch
of comedians that worked at the comedy
clubs because I didn't I didn't want to
be I didn't know about stand-up until I
started doing stand-up so I wasn't so I
was in Chris Rock who was doing Richard
Pryor right who he'll say I was doing
Richard Pryor but nobody says well
that's stealing
it's like oh you're emulating I emulated
a bunch of these young guys after that
got shed after that emulation got shed
and I built the persona of the stand-up
guy
right and I started moving forward that
is when all of all that stuff stopped
because I became myself I if you see me
perform my jokes are passion they're not
written I'm not a ever been a writing
comic my jokes aren't clever like that
they're filled with passion they're
about anger frustration watch my
specials and turn down the volume and
I'm not smiling very much I'm very
intense so my jokes are written from my
heart you know so when when I'm accused
like you said I come out with evidence
you know here's the data show me the
data but I'll give you exactly what I'm
talking about so there's a guy named one
beer yeah he's from here in 93 94 ish
around there I met him I had a show
called local slam
HBO he's really really funny young guy I
said I want to put this guy on the show
he's raw but he's really funny let's
let's add him into one of the shows and
if he's funny we'll leave him in if he's
not we'll cut him up mm-hmm that's fine
so he's on the show he makes it on three
months after the show airs he calls me
and he says hey are you gonna be in
Corpus Christi any time soon and I said
I don't know why and he said well I got
paid to do three thousand three thousand
dollars to do a headlining act I don't
have that kind of material so I did your
act and I said all right whatever man
it's yeah you know I need to write new
stuff anyway all the stuff I did in the
past is in the past it doesn't matter to
me go ahead well he ended up doing a
small tour going to army bases after a
while people started telling him hey
Carlos is doing your jokes he was a
young comedian he didn't know what to do
so he kind of just pretended but he
never really said no no it's the
opposite so about three years three and
a half years ago he and I are hanging
out and the guy says to him and I hear
him on the other side of the wall
so guys system how can you how can you
be with this guy this guy not only stole
your act but he he's he acts like you so
I heard one say it's the opposite bro
without that dude I wouldn't be where
I'm at he helped me out he paid my way
he did stuff for me he bought me shoes
to be on TV when I was on shows I did
his act I stole his persona he's my idol
not the other way around without that
guy I would never be where I'm at there
was a pause and the guy goes oh [ __ ] I'm
I don't like them anyway I can't fight
that I just can't fight that and this
this has been my frustration because
when this first started I paid a lot of
money to Consulting's and you know what
they all said don't fight it let it go
it's gonna go away
problem is the Internet was brand new
they didn't understand that the
Internet is forever not today it just
exists through time so somebody right
now right now who's a fan of mine is
discovering this for the first time and
they're gonna go on the air and it's
gonna feel brand new to them even though
this occurred if ten years ago and so my
frustration is with the lack of data and
and the wanting to you know for me to
accept certain things that I I can only
accept that which what I do it'll be in
being arrogant
well not arrogant but being being a dick
to those guys and running the light oh
god yes and you know what I deserve all
that hate but the amount of animus that
came from it and the effect of it yeah I
don't think people really really really
understood that so let me give you a
different way of asking a question here
for you Billy Graham once wrote a book
on how to debate the question of this
Jesus really exists right right and it's
a very interesting book and I read this
because I mean I was an atheist 25 years
of my life I don't believe in God let me
see what this Riley Graham has said I go
to Pasadena he's performing at Rose Bowl
I would say November 17th of oh three
because I want every day outside force
outside of a Saturday just wanna hear
this game eventually they made it the
Billy Graham day and he says you know
the challenge with Jesus is you either
think he's a psychopath right if what he
says right he's either a liar he's
either or he's the truth right so it's
one of those things right so the person
that you're debating with you're like
well I don't know if he sounds like he's
a sociopath I don't know if he is a liar
then what do you think maybe he's
telling the truth
okay he's telling the truth so if he's
telling he says I am so then the
interpretation says I really mean that
I'm God I'm this I'm that okay that's a
completely different thing the
comparison to me is you look at a Joe
Rogan who gets up and he says this guy
steals jokes why don't you go say
something I'm afraid I'm not gonna say
nothing I'm not going you know the
wonder comedians I don't want to say
anything because I want to confront him
no I'm not gonna say any code that says
this is why guys like Carlos Mencia get
away right with being able to steal
jokes from guys like you they come
listen they take your jokes they go
there bigger no one knows who you are
right right
so either Joe is a pathological liar mmm
he's either a sociopath right or he's
telling the truth right which one is in
your eyes or he had a personal problem
with me why would he have a but what he
has to be friends but we used to be
pretty decent friends at one point I I
can't I can't answer that question and I
don't whatever theories I have at this
point the it's it it's it's a negative
thing to bring up once you've chosen the
high road the non question road the non
antagonistic road you can't go back 15
years later to try to relitigate somehow
are you in anger how old are you 52
you're young yeah you young it's not
like you're 83 it's like yeah you know
it's good to go you're 52 years old and
this comedy space is at its peak right
nuts not like it's a great time right
not to be a comedian this is a
phenomenal temp/w commute right right so
when I watch Joe I say you know what I
don't think this guy's lying you know I
don't take it as this guy's line I just
think Joe was able to bring something up
and talk to and Joe was somebody that
Joe didn't care if he was gonna lose the
job while other guys cared because Joe
had a courier he was doing act and he
was doing Fear Factor I don't know he
had a bunch of different sticks that he
had that's right this is pre write any
the podcast stuff that he did right so
he says that now I'll give you I'll ask
you the second question here for you how
was how was your way of thinking
worked for you since this event 15 years
ago meaning the event happens with the
way you've responded to this event in
the last 15 years what kind of results
has your way of thinking produced for
you on the way you've processed this
issue well the first thing I had to do
was say to myself be honest look to what
you know it's that thing of if one
person says your dick if everybody says
you're a dick so I had to go back and
say what is it what is this you know
what is this animosity where's this
coming from you know so I called a bunch
of comedians and
asked him about you know did you say
this did you say that no you know what I
mean
and so I had to go okay what what what
is it you know what is it about me
because being labeled a joke thief in
what I do think about this one sentence
erases every accomplishment that I've
ever done anything
sure does I think to me it does can I
give you an argument on that to me it
does because because what we do is very
personal what we do is very internal
it's especially the way I do it and if
it if it's built on not just the backs
of somebody else
yeah but the taking of of that to me it
just a and by the way if you call in
line and somebody says I'm gonna go see
Karl's machine and somebody goes he's a
dope thief and they go oh I didn't know
that that's it erased every moment and
it happens so I had to kind of
internalize what all this was figure out
what it was about me you know figure out
what it was about others and here's if
you ever interview some of the people
that open for me
all right guys like Bobby Lee guys like
Jo koy guys like Brad Williams anyway a
bunch of them and and you asked him why
didn't you defend Carlos at the time and
they they would have told you it was at
the time toxic to even like me to even
defend me Bobby Lee actually put up a
video because what happened was with
Bobby
Ari Shaffir is about 666 whatever Bobby
is about five five so probably called me
up and he said hey he beat me up dude
like he beat me up so if you ever have
the chance don't don't book him on your
show ironically we were gonna use Ari in
a sketch that week so that night I went
to the car
a store I saw him and I said hey bro
what do you do no beating up Bobby Lee
he's like he's he's a he's a little baby
what are you doing and he said if I see
him again
I'm gonna kick his ass again so when he
responded that way I said okay well I I
didn't say anything to him but we just
didn't book him on the show we booked
somebody else
he wasn't booked on the show at the time
but so Bobby
when a lot of they started because Ari
was the one that was was in that video
saying hey Carlos did that he did a
video saying that this happened he got
so much hate in one day from that video
from the truth from his truth that he he
said I can't I can't I gotta take I
can't be a part of this I can't be like
I can't take it I can't and so this is
something that I've been dealing with
just recently because if I'm not
mistaken somebody has Joe what is the
difference between Carlos and game and
Amy and he said well people defended
those others nobody defended nobody
defended Ned because they couldn't and
you know what I've had to realize
recently I just kind of recently I used
to think there was nobody out there to
defend me but now I have to kind of deal
with the fact that some of the people
that I helped really get to you know to
grow as comedians were not we're not
there for me at that time for whatever
reason you know I can understand it but
I'm actually going through a little bit
of a grieving process because it just
was about a month ago that this kind of
it kind of clicked I was doing an
interviewing and I and I said I do have
people that could have defended me they
just chose not to and I realized that
and and and it's something that I'm kind
of still dealing with who what big name
today defends you the biggest name that
defended me is dead Robert Schimmel he
was a huge defender of mine but no one
has passed away a day of those guys I
don't know who would defy me now I think
Jo koy would now at this point why why
bread I know Brad Williams why do you
think that why do you think those big
guys who don't care what the day
supports or not why wouldn't I don't
think they would care the big guys that
you're talking about I don't know that
they would they would they would think
about it one way or the other but not
but I don't know I don't so don't I
don't hang out of comedy clubs anymore
dude but I but I do the role I'm 50 to
50 50 weeks a year on the road yeah so
you said Pat if I admit to stealing that
erases my legacy right
no no erases what what were you saying
that erase is I'm saying that when
somebody says I'm a joke see ya with
that one ten sentence to them yeah it
erases any accomplishment that I've ever
done that with that one cent I don't I
don't but there's a reason for that
though so sure how about I agree with
the bio so let me ask you so for you are
you a writer and actor or comedian which
one would you say you are I'm all of
them now you're all of them now sure in
oh five of them so you're a writer
comedian and actor yeah all three yes
okay so it's so going back to the
stealin part let's just say if you were
to come out hypothetically yes you can I
say listen screw it you know what I did
steal jokes right and I was a prick and
I was an [ __ ] and I hurt some people
and re I didn't book I mean I didn't
book this guy and I did this to a few
people right say you did that mm-hmm
what do you think would happen I have no
idea but that would that would kill my
soul because it would I don't know that
I'd be able to live with myself because
I'd be doing it for the reaction I
wouldn't be doing it so that people
would just be like okay he's cool let it
go you know what I mean I don't know
that I could do that what I can do is
say look I have literal evidence of when
I perform jokes and if you can you can
tell me one then then I will say oh my
god I did in yours buddy it's 15 when
you say that like your died I said nope
I've been saying this forever but I get
it but what you're saying right now when
you say that it's it's it's almost like
taking the approach of if you can show
proof that I did X Y Z and take money
from the bank
when it's the jokes you have to do that
because first of all there's okay
right now the coronavirus okay do you
know how many of us are doing a joke
about no I drink all day long or no I
drink tequila or whatever version is
that joke yeah a lot of us are okay
right so but if I'm the first one to do
that joke right and I can prove that
that's that's real and that's not go
prove it
that that's me saying like look I know
when I did it if you're accusing me of
something
then then tell me when because I look I
don't mind I'm a flawed human being all
right I wouldn't mind I don't have a
problem saying that when I was young I
was an amalgamation of comedians I don't
have a problem with that and if those
guys were to say to me you stole my
stuff I would legitimately oblate I'm
sorry the but that's not that's not it
look in the past year I've called a
bunch of comedians to apologize for
bumping them and running the light and
going on before them and doing that kind
of stuff every single one of them at the
end of that conversation I've said to
them hey man do we need to talk about
jokes stealing is that something that
you and I have to have a conversation
about and it's all come back know so I
don't these hypothetical young comics
that you're talking about I don't know
who they are I remember I remember
somebody in El Paso the Gold Coast of my
joke I hadn't even been to a peso in two
years don't even know who this guy was
it was it's hard to explain the way it
was but it was it was cool to hate me it
was cool to not like me that doesn't
that's I know or like a victim saying no
no because because it's a Basque other
but it's easy no but but but because I
bumped him because I took something from
them and it wasn't a joke it's I took
their time I took their stage time I
took the the one most important thing to
a comedian that's even more important
than a joke because you can't tell the
joke unless you get onstage can't tell a
joke unless you actually get to perform
it I took that from these guys
so that that pain from them was real but
let's talk about integrity all right
so Steve rent is easy right he's on that
video accusing me of being a joke thief
accusing my integrity this is a guy who
lied about being in the World Trade
Center during the 9/11 attacks to garner
you know sympathy
that's a guy who was questioning at the
time my integrity so I can I this was
this has been this has been the issue
for a long time like how do i what do i
do you know I go up to comedians I say
hey do we need to talk about this I
don't I don't know what Joe has no
reason to call you out though of course
he does what's the reason for Joe to
call you out at the time he and I were
we still are I guess when it comes to
comedy competitive in nature when we all
are listen watch that watch a watch a
documentary it's about the rise of
comedy in the Boston area and how it was
just a beautiful communal thing until
one of them ended up on The Tonight Show
and when that happened they all became
enemies they all fought each other
because you have to understand who we
are we're comedians writer actor
director producer on stage by ourselves
our egos are astonishing astonishing so
the competitive nature of who you are is
is is huge huge and if you look at the
styles of comedy too aggressive guys
trying to be smart angry screaming there
was a competitive nature to it I can
tell you that so it was I don't know I
am talking manipulative to say you're
stealing jokes it would be minute jokes
but but that was that was in the ether
from the beginning of my career right
that was that I was that but I that
wasn't made up that wasn't manner so you
were stealing jokes no no what I'm
saying is that
was in the ether from me being a young
comic from me going through like I said
it was I didn't get to be in Addison
Texas doing
Paul Rodriguez jokes when I did Paul
Rodriguez I did it on stage at the
Comedy Store on Sunset Boulevard so when
I did anything similar it was out there
for everybody to see
so for me from when I was young that I
had heard that kind of stuff you know so
me and some of the other comics we you
know we were part of that whole thing so
that was in the ether is what I was
saying I'd listen I wish I would love to
I've had this conversation with you're
not the only person that said just you
know say I'm sorry and move on I would
love to I don't know what apologize to
and those people that I have I've called
them and none of them have know none of
them have said apologize for that but
look it brings me great great great
unbelievable sadness because I wish that
this could have a simple resolution like
Mia culpa you know what I mean I'm a
Catholic bro I know you know poor Mia
culpa mea culpa poor me gram culpa I get
it bro I'm not that guy but I just I
can't acquiesce to a hypothetical
because you question my motives but not
the accusers I don't know what to say to
that
oh I don't so I I understand what you're
saying but I don't look at it from that
standpoint I'm just asking saying he
doesn't come across as a guy that would
do it with ill intentions he would come
across as the guy doing it to trying to
protect his peers
now I understand he's fully competitive
I don't it when you're saying that I can
fully see that I mean at that level of
the game you have to be competitive he's
on the MMA world so of course he's very
competitive right but I just I just
looked in ice okay so you got you got
Canseco you got a rod okay very an
interesting example here Canseco Iran
okay mm-hmm Canseco comes out and says
hey not only am i juicing but here's a
list of right and here's a book right
since it throws everybody under the bus
right you know it's like hey I'm
stealing Joe I'm everybody stole jokes
so here's what we're doing okay
a rod goes on 60 minutes have you used
there no have you done this no but and
then but then what he does afterwards he
says I did I apologize right let me and
then now today today you can't turn on
the channel TV without seeing his face
he's everywhere right and he's loved
respected back at it again and he was in
a city in New York where everybody
looked at jido and said this has never
come back to be right a rod a rod is
doing great right Canseco right no and
it's not like one both our angels and
both did everything right right but one
guy just came out and said yeah here's
what's going on right without throwing
anybody under the bus and he's on the
limelight that's what I've done when it
comes to everything I just you religious
a rod on on you know because see again
I'm not I'm I put it all out there it's
I've never I've never skirted the issue
look it's 15 years later I probably
shouldn't even be doing this interview
in this way
this is hashing up stuff that for some
people's in the past for some people as
long ago whatever it is I got listen I
get it but I've always been truthful
with with regards to how I come about
this and listen for four minutes for me
to say that I took time from these young
comics you know that's that's not a best
that's horrible so just just to just do
so I got you is I don't I'm not fearful
of saying that's the last question I've
been a joke for you now never soul a
joke never never saw what I'm saying
when I was a young comic not only did I
steal don't I emulated these guys I did
it the way Paul Rodriguez did it I did
it the way Freddie Prinze did it I did
it the way George Carlin did it but I
was a young comedian learning how to be
a comedian so that was the beginning of
my once I started to become Carlos you
know what I mean however long that took
then it became me my jokes my
personality my thing my thinking my
process so that's what I'm saying but
when I was doing mind of Mencia no I was
taking young comic stuff I was not I was
not I wasn't even at comedy clubs long
enough before after my performances - do
you know what I do when I was doing
minor Mencia I go to the Laugh Factory
do it whatever long minutes act and then
I go to the Comedy Store and then I go
to the Improv and then I go home I
wasn't watching I wasn't watching other
comics I wasn't I wasn't seeing what
they were doing I didn't know what they
were doing I had no clue what they were
doing you know what I mean so I don't
know it's uh look I like I said man it'd
be pains me I I have I would have no
problem whatsoever telling the truth I'm
not in the world I was in the world I
would say okay if itself somebody's
watching us right under comedian they're
saying well Carlos stole my joke in 2004
and he did this so it you're saying
there's no one that's gonna watch it
that's gonna say Carlos at one point
took my joke and he told it at a big
you're saying no one's gonna come out
and say that that's what I hope so so
that I could go back and pull out a tape
for 2004 2003 and I could say oh my god
you're right you did do it before my
sincere apologies
that's the that's the engineer side of
you that answered that that's a that's a
political you just gave a very brilliant
that shows the brains can you a very
smart guy you're not a you're you're a
brilliant guys there's a point but if
that's more why am i taking other
people's jokes especially after being
accused of doing so it doesn't make any
sense I would have to be I know a lot of
smart guys [ __ ] no but but but I like
it but I've got to tell you this part I
got to pay this part I've been in
business long enough where I'm in a
business of having to read people it's
my job it's what I get paid to do right
if I don't do it I'm out of business I'm
supposed to do it to know if this sales
guy that's telling me this or this
investor I'm sitting in board meeting my
entire gig without it you're not gonna
exist right okay if I look at a guy like
you I've been in rooms where I have guys
that are brilliant people semi genius
let me make the point semi genius but
sometimes a guy that semi genius
I don't know why the more talented
people are sometimes they're lazier okay
interest sometimes people that are less
talented sometimes I have to work
harder so sometimes the naturally
talented guys like dude I'm just gonna
I'm just gonna tell her better than he
does I got a Wang pad what had one guy
tell me this I want some I put on an
event an event you know I put it on but
three weeks later he put on the same
exact event was dressed just like and he
put on the same skit grew the same
message everything was the same right
but he asked me please don't say from
stage that this was the same exact good
as you and back then in oh wait guess
what one I there's no social media so I
can't like put it up and say say it's
the same thing right I said no problem
then one night we're together it's four
o'clock in the morning at his place he
says you know what you know what my
biggest strength is I said what he says
my biggest strength is watching you to
see what you do I just know how to do it
better
Wow watching you tell a story I just
know how to do it better sometimes there
are guys out there that are geniuses
that know how to watch and mimic body
language just do a better job at it than
another person that is a form of genius
genius isn't just about you writing
everything the form of geniuses I'm too
lazy to write it I'm just gonna do
better than that guy does so you're
saying no every job you have you seen
have you seen my stand-up specials I
have yeah do you see you see that
passion in there that's that every joke
that I think you're say I've written
well I think you're sick is what I'm
trying to tell you I'm telling you
you're insanely talented bro that there
is nothing better I know but what I'm
saying is that that stuff I could I
could actually tell you when I wrote
those jokes I wrote those just when
inspired those jokes what inspired the
passion I'm smart enough to know that I
could apologize and put an end to this
and and it's it wouldn't be it wouldn't
it wouldn't hurt me so it doesn't come
across as a liar to me it wouldn't it
wouldn't hurt me dude Joe doesn't come
across as a liar honor it was so I come
across as a lot no you don't come across
as a liar you come across as somebody
that's worried that if you were to say
this everybody would take all the other
stuff out on the legacy and say no man
boo it's already done oh god you're so
wrong what do you mean it's already done
it in my from my perspective my legacy
is already tarnished I disagree and and
their therein lies the difference
between you and I no look at me
I truly truly believe from the bottom of
my soul right that for the rest of my
life as you brought up Robin Williams my
name will be product this way and I
would love love love to push a reset or
reboot or think that that was gonna
happen
so this is my main route listen I'm not
my point is I'm not saving anything me
there's nothing I'm not protecting
anything what whatever your perception
of it is my perception of it is it's
it's done I will always have an asterisk
by my name no matter what I don't so my
point is I understand why you would say
that but my point to you is if that's
the case then I would say it because I
would be putting I'm not protecting
anything so you have nothing to produce
olette me give you an idea I am naked
are you baseball gone naked are you a
sports guy yes okay you like baseball
love it there's Pete Rose belong in a
Hall of Fame uh no based on the
standards no no there's none the
standards of no well let me see in the
Hall of Fame yes but only because his
numbers prior to juicing were appalled
of Fame before that Roger Clemens same
thing his numbers before anyone off
we're done a rod you know what I don't
know I don't know that much about when
he started thirty six one one his rookie
year then yeah the guy came out so so
all those guys that had something pretty
previous to that yes yeah so so those
guys belonging you don't think people's
does okay let me ask you did something
afterwards to betray to betray the game
in a different but he bet on himself he
didn't bet on the opponent he did I get
it but that but that's but that's bait
that's I get that base I totally I'm
with you I can respect that I think
people aren't in the Hall of Fame but I
think I ran base but I haven't been yes
I think we don't get in got you know I
think he's gonna get in after he passes
I just hope they do it while he's alive
cuz I'd be very emotional all right if
they do it right but okay so now let's
continue so we're talking about that
Astros what happened when Astros I'm
about your fan okay I'm a Dodger fan I
flew into LA to watch Game seven I'm at
the game to watch I don't
five to two and you know I was there the
picture of Dodgers didn't help too much
because right about there to 0k right so
okay so I'm a Texas Rangers fan and I'm
a Dodgers fan okay so what Houston is
doing today mm-hmm you can't turn on the
TV or first steak or ESPN or you know
anybody without hearing a bunch of
people bashing these guys on what
they're doing right what do you thing
about what they did what Astros did so
it's accepted that if you get to second
base and you you take it that's accepted
in baseball for some reason right
everybody but the way they
systematically did it is pretty
unacceptable that being said as a Dodger
fan even if they gave us the trophy you
wouldn't feel like we we want it but you
know it's uh it's painful to look back
and go what would have happened had that
not been the case okay
what would happen would have been
Yankees or Dodgers that just don't want
it anyways it's just right okay
so stealing signs has this has been
going on for a while
yes yes it's part of the game and even
back on base hank here and you know even
say look if you can do it do it right
but he didn't like the way Astros did it
right what do you think should happen
with Astros do you think days keep the
World Series or have an asterisk next to
it they should take the World Series
away but not give it to anybody else
I agree with you we're on the same page
there okay do you think if they go the
way they've been going mm-hmm you think
they're gonna be forgiven throughout the
season if the way Astros are gone which
two days I know it's my tattoo my wife
gets upset my boys come on I don't want
to do that and I'm just a regular guy
the shtick is not working right it's
working against them right correct
do you think if they go that way do you
think the punishment their opponents are
gonna give is gonna be less than the
punishment Ali could have given them I
don't know
I've no idea I don't know I mean they're
gonna get hit but that's not a big deal
that's not a big you okay but look at
the end of the day they're champions of
that year that's just forever the way
it's gonna be
and this what we're talking about it'll
be a footnote in history but here's the
question I'm going to what if these guys
came out and said
we messed up we don't want the
championship right we'll give it back
you will give the ring back we messed up
right pologize we'll be good citizens of
the MLB the fact that we didn't get
suspended in this car in this country
they probably people would want people
who would move on people would move on I
cooker this is America I agree the
person you're saying you think it's over
with okay
it's done with your legacy the guy that
made $80,000 289 million dollars two
years ago his tour was called
irresponsible tour and we went and
opened up and just that became his story
and he's one of the most loved he's
gonna be a billionaire he's one of the
most loved guys around America because
he just got her says this time I screwed
up I don't know if you've seen my show
or not I know a few of you have you seen
no Kevin are yes it's insane I mean the
way he does I just love it right on out
how he does it right you're look at here
look Wow right pretty freakin awesome
right eddie murphy's off because of some
of the issues he had with Paul Mooney
you've heard some of this stuff maybe he
didn't come because 30 years all this
other stuff great he's back on SNL and
you know what honestly it was emotional
sure you know it's kind of like that's
kind of I saw this cool man and
everybody showed up and Chappelle and
rock and everybody you know I'm this guy
get out of here when I just it's kind of
cool right I think America is my dad
told me this a long time ago when we
came here so let me tell America's built
he said America likes new heroes I agree
but when they get new heroes America
loves to see that new hero fall right
but what America loves even more is to
see that fallen hero redeem himself and
come back up
completely greater I think you have a
big opportunity to do that man
I agree but here's the problem you want
me to or people want me to accept
something that I didn't do in the way
that they say that I did I don't know I
and I'm smart enough to know that I
could apologize move on and whatever but
like I said I've called these guys
personally I've asked him about it it
doesn't come up other than in moments
like this I don't know what to say to
you maybe one day
you you should ask you know Joe if you
have a month why why he did it
what his impetus was you know I don't
know maybe even reached out to him okay
so from my perspective here's a guy who
who purposely tried to ruin my career
and in many ways succeeded I've never
done anything to him I have nothing to
apologize to him for he's one person
that I never bumped in everyone before
him when he was on schedule always on
but after him I don't have any reason to
call him if I did I would it would seem
disingenuous it from my opinion because
what would I say so I say you hired me
and it's called a big David PR firm
right I'm your publicist right and I'm
your attorney yeah so I'm a guy that got
my JD tell me something better than the
hundreds of thousands of dollars I've
spent on guys telling me to do that now
watch this we're sitting up actually
yeah and I'm doing a pro bono I don't
even want your money okay okay we're
friends we went to you got a four-year
degree we went to college again right
and we party together and we always got
along right right we went to clubs we
had a blast we have great stories we
have stories on you're right you've seen
me hammer plastered you have to wake me
up and put me in a car okay so we're
talking absolutely all right yeah I say
do you know what Carlos you say what I
said dude how confident are you that you
didn't do any of this stuff Pat I'm
telling you I'm a hundred percent
confident nothing yeah I'm telling you
I'm a hardier percent confident broke
you're that confident I think you should
send out a tweet and say 'hey if joe is
willing to have me on his show and we go
live and he wants to bring any other
friends that he wants to say that this
happened i'm willing to go on i've done
that through proxies not proxies public
oh I've done that with friends of his
debt
I have befriended that's not how to do
it though if you are that confident in
what you're doing because if you go on
Twitter right now and you say Joe it's
been 15 years
I want to know why you were so mad at me
right I'm willing to come ask me any
question you want
I have no problem doing that have you
done that no I'd love to see you because
I've done it like I said through proxies
but but but this is ability routes
through friends of you know friends of
his that I'd be friend and said hey
reach out to it's a big difference do ya
look I mean guess where the world wants
to see that only one place I mean your
world only wants to see they don't want
to see you here I'm not in your world
right I'm just a guy that's you know
from the outside I'm running a business
guy I understand but but I tell you if
you send that message out here's what's
gonna happen all of a sudden next thing
you know like wait wait wait what did he
just say right now you got 1,000
retweets 2,000 you put it on Instagram
3000 tag Joe Rogan Joe's people are
gonna contact you that and they're gonna
say come on down then that's gonna get
20 million views and if he calls you out
the viewers are gonna make a decision
and they're gonna say [ __ ] you know what
I believe him but they're gonna say dude
Rogan called them out on that three
things that he knows that nobody else
knows and he finally said yes you're
right I did do those three things and at
the end they shook hands they walked off
freaking awesome now let's see what
we're gonna do next I think you ought to
do it and but again pro bono I'm not
asking you for anything no no it's a
good idea because I think what that's
gonna do I just kept all that that kind
of site wouldn't do that look you know
because under if if you're saying what
you're saying I believe Joe and I think
Joe's a good guy when I watch his stuff
he's the only content created that I
actually it's a lot of good content
creators I'm not taking anything away
from them but what Joe somebody that to
me he's like a it's gonna sound weird
walter kronkite with a lot of f-bombs
because when he gives us a pin you know
what I'm saying when I say Walter crunk
up a lot of f-bombs because Joe is not a
Sean Hannity he's not a Glenn Beck he's
not a Anderson Cooper he's not a Rachel
Maddow
he's just Joe Rogan this is who I am I'm
not leaning on any sell political he'll
have Bernie Sanders come on says I like
this guy he'll say Trump is a badass so
you don't even know where this guy's at
so I think you know if there is only one
place for you to go to do this
and how should I be there and I think at
that point if there are some things that
he says that you screwed up you say do
it okay
I'm sorry right you say those magical
words to him or his peers I am telling
you right now if I'm a betting man I
would be willing to bet that 6 12 24 36
months later you got a Netflix special
or something like that going on for
yourself and at 55 years old now you got
another 15 year run rate to go out then
you don't have to like an interesting
idea I am proposing it whatever I do
there's another side to that where it
just brings up all negative stuff and
you know like you know that's that that
that's what's it's what negative stuff
just all of it whatever it is talking
about negative sokar there's no negative
here no no I'm saying look the minute I
post that I'm gonna start reading you
know what you did blah blah blah blah
rate it it's don't read it
listen I'm telling you again it's hard I
know what is we do for a living this is
our soul you're not talking to other
people he's mine we'd worry of it well I
would touch it I will put it and I
wouldn't even look at it
well I'm not even gonna look at it I had
Jordan Peterson here I don't know if you
know Jordan Peterson Jordan Peterson is
clinical psych is a clinical
psychologist Toronto professor one time
he the way he became big is he went
against a transvestite on campus and he
kind of debated it and he became big and
then next thing you know he gets a few
billion views and he's a big name okay
I've had him in few a couple times and
we had him at the event while he's at
the event I asked him a question he gets
emotional starts crying right it's colic
whoa why is this guy getting emotional
right guy I had him here and I said tell
me about Twitter how do you look at
Twitter he says you know I gotta tell
you Twitter's very painful so why is it
so painful this is because people are
vicious you know they come out and say
stuff that I stay up for Twitter and he
says I when I post I don't like to look
at what people say so if you're going to
commit to doing this obviously you know
you gonna have to think about a
processor talk talk to your wife to go
this right because you know if you do
you're gonna get the call right I don't
know about that I think
will because I think if you don't I
think if you you're in power play if you
do that you're in the power position
because if he doesn't you said I'm out
here
I mean he's not us but I've I've done
this before he's not the same we as
public because public the audience gets
behind you know the public we're getting
behind you we're saying yeah we want to
see this right okay get on let's see
what's gonna happen right and it's like
dude this is great you know what I like
the guy you know I want to give him a
second I'd go watch his show now you
start opening up all this sometimes it
flips you know I I had a sometimes in
life you're the head boss you're the
face right mhm and everybody else is
kind of hanging off your coattail right
you know how that is it's kind of oh my
gosh if I hang out with Carlos I'm gonna
be doing shows you first hit it's great
it's awesome to be here sometimes life
goes like this and it humbles us right
any you'd kind of like damn I hate this
position no one likes this position
because you would have faced this is not
easy that's a great position it's a
learning position it is if you're coming
from the step when you were saying right
now of course everything's a learning
beautiful perience it's it's I wouldn't
be the kind of person I am without all
these negative things it's it's the
hardest part is what's out of your
control that's that's the part that's
you know the part that's look it's it's
not easy to sit here as somebody who has
the integrity to accept my flaws to hear
somebody like you say well I believe him
therefore I don't believe you it's not
an easy thing that's not an easy
position to be for somebody like me
because I get when I first started doing
set when I first started doing stand-up
when I first started becoming Carlos
Mitzi shore said to me you bleed on
stage and I said well what do you mean I
bleed on stage she's like you're just
that's coming out that's coming out of
your blood what you're talking about
that passion that's your bleeding on
stage this is what I do my my whole life
is built on making people happy bringing
people joy
and and having having the integrity to
look back at who I am and who I've been
and accept you know things you know when
when that guy said yeah whatever Carlos
[ __ ] them anyway I don't like him it
hurt you know and and to to be sitting
here fifteen years after that you know
what I mean and me and me not shying
away from it not being evasive about it
not saying you know what that happened a
long time ago let's one it's time being
completely open about it it's uh it
saddens me to to it's just if it wasn't
for the fact that I have a show tonight
and I'm gonna get to purge this feeling
that I have right now this sadness yeah
I don't know where I would be as a human
being like that's that's that's how real
it is so I like I said I've tried
everything but at the end of the day I
have no control over it and so I must I
must let it go but it's but you know
it's not easy to hear it's not easy to
hear I believe the integrity of others
other than you in in a video that had
people that have shown to not have
integrity guys like Ari Shaffir who got
in trouble recently because of what he
did you know guys like Steve Rannazzisi
tenor etc you know these are the people
that were accusing me of all this that's
all I'm sorry I'm not my mistake I want
to say this part to you I want to say
this part to you hear me out here I want
to say this part to you
I like Antonia Browns game you have no
idea how much I love this game this is a
guy this is super talented right
Steelers Rossa Raiders clowns Gruden
right then goes to Patriots clowns down
well that's not what happened but would
that mean he got caught with you know
Jamison yeah okay
but still he left he still didn't really
give him the love you owe me this much
you know a little bit consciously when I
look at Antonia Brown first thing I
posted is I don't know who the hell is
in his ear
sometimes who's in our ear oh I
completely agree either puts fear in us
or makes us like for example let's just
say if I'm in your ear you don't know me
you know I mean why would you trust me
you just we just met right now sure
you're not like if somebody were to say
do you trust Patrick we do I don't know
the guy just met him right now it's not
like we go friend and we're best friends
in high school okay but sometimes I had
people in my life personal life
very close blood close right there's a
big difference right and they say yeah
bro let me tell you man
you know I wouldn't do it I would tell
them this and there was no way in the
world on another in that moment you
think you're more loyal to this guy then
a stranger that's telling you better
feedback right then what this is telling
you sometimes right so you're like yeah
bro you know I only got five people that
have my in my back that have my back I
don't know who's in your ear it's none
of my business
I don't know now nobody I don't know
who's giving you counsel back on those
days a bunch dude I get that but some
crisis management the people who all
said this some of the best people giving
you canceled or people that you don't
say but I got I got you some of the best
people they take counsel they're people
that you don't pay no I didn't listen
they're just kind of like dude here's
what I would say right all I'm saying to
you is I'm not calling you a liar bro
all I'm saying to you is I don't know
who's in your ear and whatever way
you're processing the decision if you
think you're right I suggest take the
strategy and go see what happens yeah if
if you don't then don't it is all good
maybe if you don't want to go back into
it but all I know is some tells me that
the upside reward is bigger with that
approach then the current approach
something tells me and I'm not saying to
you go in there and say bro do you just
want me to tell you that it did it I did
it I don't know I'm not saying that I'm
not saying that I'm just saying the feud
started with two guys if you go out
there and you say here's what happened
you guys sit down you hash it out then
the viewer can say I don't agree with
Carlos here I really Joe here's the
thing just listen
most people don't know how that video
how that video came to be right that
video came to be because
when when Jill was on stage he was in he
was introducing a friend of mine who
opened for me at the time and he said
the sky opens for Carlos Minsky Leah
right so I went onstage and I said hey
bro if you're gonna call me that what
joke of yours did I steal this is the
kind of person that I am the kind of
person that I'd been I didn't run from
the moment shy from the moment I
literally went up onstage with arrogance
but not arrogance with my cockiness but
with a sense of humility of hey what
what did I take from you that you're
this mad at me and that's how it started
I've never said anything bad about the
guy never never never tried to hurt the
guy in any way never done anything and
you know there were moments but it's
it's look if you don't if you believe
him then it's obvious it you don't
believe me because we're on opposite
ends it's okay I'm just telling you that
it's being the kind of person than I am
and as open as I am it's difficult
because people want to believe what they
want to believe and know it's it's
listen it's true for whatever reason it
is I am smart enough to know that an
apology in some way shape or form would
negate a lot of this stuff and I would
love to do that my integrity won't let
me because what these guys are accusing
me of it's not anything I did even when
somebody would say oh well you just
changed to joke a little bit it's like
what do you mean I change the joke so
it's a different joke I don't get it
like all I can do is maintain the
integrity I owe not oh not only do I
record all the shows but at the end of
this at the end of every single show I
do you can get a copy of the show that
you saw so everything I've ever done is
not even within my realm it's out there
like people have this stuff I've been
recording shows since back in the day
when I record on a little thing called
that a digital small little audio
recorder
that I would then take it home I would
put it onto cassettes and Mail those
cassettes to people that's how long ago
I've been doing that so my material has
been out there for 30 years I you know
that that's that's where I lie and you
know you get to a point where you I've
gotten to a point where it feels at
times futile and this is why you know
I've had to go to therapy because there
there have been moments where this
sadness is so so just resounding and
that voice in my head saying just you
know say you're sorry and move on and it
says like I can't for that I can say I'm
sorry I bumped you I'm sorry I didn't
think about you I'm sorry then I went on
long I'm sorry that your mom was there
or somebody was there and they didn't
get to see you
I I can do that and and and know that
that that was painful for these guys
part of me is like that's what happened
to me I feel like I feel like the guy
who got hazed and then the year after I
didn't get the haze anybody because it
was not appropriate anymore
but you know at a certain point I just I
I don't know what to do other than you
know what I mean other than just deal
with it and move on and and and you know
it's nothing that I've uh
I don't even lay I'm less forwards I
don't know I don't even know how to I
don't even know how to answer I don't
even know how to feel it's just it's
just so it's a it's a deep deep deep
sorrow man it really is so let me ask
you are you pretty comfortable posting
that on Twitter Instagram or social
media or know right now just right horse
okay so you're going to prom with that
okay no he's so curious no you know
what's gonna happen with that not at all
because like I said look I have never
ever ever tried to escape this because I
was fully aware that as a young comic I
was guys that you don't know I was
Charles Cozart
I was Steve Greenlee I was John
Habanera I I can tell you the names I
know these guys right you know I wasn't
doing their jokes I was them you know I
have no problem it's just outside of
that when you've been told by many many
people who supposedly know better than
you just let it go let it be and you let
it go and you let it be you know in 15
years later this interview happens you
just kind of sit back and go what the
[ __ ] do I need to do like did I've
answered every question that's ever been
posed to me from every single angle of
all of this stuff and it has never been
enough for a certain segment of society
and listen last week some guy in Houston
said who Stokes are you gonna do so I
said well come and see me perform and
I'll give you two tickets and he says
what do you expect
I said nothing just tell the world what
you see and after that didn't hear
anything
no positive no negative he didn't say
yeah he did it but he also didn't say I
was wrong it was great it was funny you
know this this is this is the futility
that I go through and I feel when
moments like this happen I I approached
this from an open standpoint I always
have I look at the fact that this keeps
coming back and in this respect you know
I just feel like your ideas he was good
I don't know I never wanted to so to
speak stir the pot in that respect so
I've kept that part of it like hey I'd
love to be on the show and talk about
anything that wants to be talked about
as long as we can be open about mm-hmm
everything about everything all the
stuff whatever personal stuff happened
all of it then I'm okay with it
but you know I've gotten no response
other than other than well he's
I think what I was told was he'd shake
your hand right now if you know you guys
were at a club or something like that me
like okay but from my perspective look
at it from my perspective I'm being
accused of something that I can't defend
from him and when I go to others I don't
get back so this this is somebody that
has literally started his podcasts by
making me an issue you know about
talking about me bringing me up too so
this was in way way way way back in the
beginning I was a big part of that and
the negative aspect of me and so I I've
never said anything bad
therefore I don't know what to say
outside of your idea is an interesting
idea I I actually think it would be it
would be a do I do I have a problem with
that I think not you hit none whatsoever
I think it'd be hit because either way
you don't lose right high the way you
don't lose sounds interesting
yeah she doesn't respond you don't lose
he responds you win right yeah so you
going you sit down okay I'm sure he's
gonna call you it on some stuff we're
gonna say come on Carlos and you're
gonna see you know I believe Joe here
and then there's gonna be some reason
like Joe maybe you're pushing too much
in this area then you're gonna get some
fan base but either way look I mean
you've seen Tyson biting Evander when
they sat down it's like that was awesome
when you saw magic and I say Thomas
magic was a big part obviously Jordan
didn't have Isaiah beyond a dream
playing because you know why you know
this story I mean it says you walk out
you don't even shake our hands after we
beat you all these learners I was
shaking here you don't want to shake my
hand okay I'm not doing this right right
but magic also politically was able to
heart Isaiah a little bit because you
know Isaiah was talking about the fact
that magic you know they had some issues
with his health mm-hmm when they did
their sit down
Isaiah got emotional dude eyeballs I see
he's got junk just on the cheek on them
yeah I was emotion but yeah but you know
who you know who won
guess who won fans one sure and I say
was like do it
I got a thousand pounds off my back and
magics like look man I'm sorry as well
so you kind of a little bit it's all a
little bit of both I don't know I I just
I just so you know when you think about
controversy with Joe his top controversy
is who you it's not the fear factor all
its you you're at the top okay well they
there you go this is an opportunity and
I'm not from America I wasn't born I was
born in Iran and lived there ten years
two years in Germany had a refugee camp
but America is a place that forgives
right that's why this is such a
beautiful place completely forgives and
then after that you know if and when
this happens and everything takes place
you and I will get on the phone and I'll
say so how you feeling then you know hey
Pat this kind of ended up working out
great awesome and if it didn't it just
goes on and you move on and do your
thing yeah but I just feel different
than any other day exactly that's what
I'm saying - but the upside is way too
big to not upon us yeah I am I don't
want to stir negativity but but it
sounds worded properly take a weekend
simmer on it take that we can simmer on
it just got I wouldn't I wouldn't do it
tonight I wouldn't do it I would just
take a week course and just go process
very emotional babe what do you think
that and then you you do it you do it
you don't you don't but I'm just glad we
were able to have this conversation you
know for me it was more kind of like I'm
sitting I'm like you know what I just
want to talk to Carlos and I won't know
how he's gonna respond to my idea that's
someone we reached out I said I don't
know if he's gonna come on or not
because here's a guy that he interviews
some presidents and Kobe and these guys
what if he asked me some tough questions
and he's got mobsters on he's got all
this other stuff but if Carlos says yes
we'll have a good time together and I
got to tell you I had a blast with you
man yeah seriously I had a blast with
you what time are you performing tonight
by the way I think 8 o'clock at what
time what time is it right now 6 o'clock
ok I am going to today's what day today
is
there's I'm gonna come tonight I'm gonna
come show up tonight and I'm gonna come
watch you to show support and maybe a
couple of us go there to show support I
said we go there tonight to show support
I like redemption stories and I'd love
to see this one take place I think
there's a opportunity
for the world of comedy if you know some
stuff happens later on some people gonna
look back and look at you and say wow
you know hey can I call you and you
become that counsel for some of the
younger guys coming up I think it's a
different I know you happen but I think
at a larger scale that also brings more
money to you and you're able to enjoy
life because when you're 52 I remember
one time a singer once said dar you sh
i'm at a concert and he's singing this
song and Dariush in iran was known as a
guy that was using a lot of drugs mhm
mhm and in Iran you know you when you
were drug in Iran you didn't admit to it
right so I like you know is like you
know yeah hey I smoke weed it's not like
America absent friends yeah so you know
how they are right back a lot of pride
right so he didn't want to say dude one
day this guy gets up and he says I
freakin used everything right he's got
four million fans on Facebook right he
goes to a place sells everybody shows up
and he's on stage performing I just had
a surgery at the time I had lost my
voice for six months and I did a surgery
they thought it was cancer but it was
benign they cut and a doctor so he can't
talk so my brother-in-law calls me CL
Mac and he says I want to take you to
this concert okay let's go and he sings
a few songs and he pauses he's a very
low-key almost like a depressing love
songs of how much he misses Iran nothing
is like yeah you know dancing right so
he says I have to apologize to you guys
he says because I never wrote music that
was played at happy places like weddings
he says I wish I would have been more
invited to weddings right unfortunately
my songs were more played during you
know sorrow times of differently then he
says if there's any advice I can give
you guys for the people here that are
30s 40s 20s it says just make sure the
young wolf in you takes care of the old
wolf you're one day be he says because
I'm an old wolf now I don't have the
level of ambition I had when I was
younger right just make sure you take
care of the old you my suggestion to you
is to take care of the 72 year old
Carlos Mencia that's all it is Matt is
not like I said
yeah and I'm glad you're doing that I
think it's I've had a lot of friends who
have gone through some challenging times
and therapy's helped a ton and I'm Bobby
from suicide that's the biggest part
that you're saying that biggest part
that it's worked for you yeah it's work
for you but again appreciate you for
coming out I'm gonna come and join you
tonight
and I'm looking forward to laughing
because when you when you tell jokes I
laughs I want to laugh a little bit
tonight appreciate it and maybe we'll
get a chance to spend some time together
after the show sure buddy thanks for
coming out man
anytime I thank you yep we cover a lot
of different topics with Carlos and it
was interesting kind of seeing him going
into giving his perspective his point of
view there was some moments of friction
I'm actually curious to know what you
think about it do you believe what he's
saying do you not do you you know see
his point of view if you have you had an
experience with them did you work with
them if you did comment below and if you
enjoyed the sit-down with Carlos Mencia
you're probably gonna also enjoy the
sit-down I had with Kevin Hart if you
want to watch that click over here and
if you're not subscribed to the channel
please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye bye
you
[Music]